how do you think new york
illinois
and california's policies did during
covet how do you think they did i'm
actually really curious what you're
going to say here
which which states go one adam go just
do new york and california how do you
think they how do you think their
leaders handle code listen i don't agree
with how they handled it either tell me
what you don't agree with what i what
would you do i'm actually really curious
what do you think they didn't do right
so here's what i would have done okay
okay because i can't i don't like i
can't tell you every single decision
that any of the other states i was
solely focused on but you have to
realize if you're gonna sit down and get
the votes of people here who moved from
another state and you can't explain why
they left and you don't know their
pressure points you're gonna have a hard
time getting them to listen to you so
here here's my here's mine sure okay so
first and foremost i did ask for him to
close down because we could have saved
lives and you may not disagree but i'm
telling you those signs there's lots of
science not like that i i and you and i
a lot of things didn't work the mask
mandates didn't work and the vax mandex
didn't work we have plenty of signs to
back that and i i completely disagree
that if we had shut down or if that were
true though nikki new york wouldn't have
had the surges that it did in california
wouldn't have had the surges that it did
despite those policies in fact new york
and california oftentimes looked a lot
worse than florida well not for very
long but the problem
the point was to have closed down
earlier because if we had closed down
earlier we would have stopped the spread
earlier not people are getting covered
like crazy even now this isn't different
this is totally different strain they're
ever there's 70 percent works though you
know that i mean everybody got covet
people who were vax people who were
unvaccinated different streams waves
some of it was seasonal we know that now
we know come on we also all know that
people get vaccinated they're not going
to get into the hospital that's not true
either i know plenty of people who got
vaccinated who landed in the hospital
that's not true yes yes and some parents
died
that is not true though that's not
that's not to say that people shouldn't
get the vaccine if they want to get the
vaccine or people should have access to
do whatever they want to do for their
health but to argue that shutting down
florida would have prevented the spread
of covenants not backwards let's also
realize this desantis did shut down the
state the state was shut down let's not
forget that he did shut down the state
okay he also when i said it closed it
down earlier so we could open it back
earlier that has always been my position
so so every time that ron wants to say
you know the liberals would shot down
the same would still be shut down it's
absolutely flat out so you would have
shut it down earlier but oh so that
opened it and then did you support the
mandates of the vaccine mandates no no
you didn't i did not i came out and said
personal choice
everybody has to make the decisions i
went against the white house and said
look you know at this point you know
what you need to do to protect yourself
you know what you need to be doing in
order to get your family safe um i did
go on to every single day and ask people
to get the vaccine but certainly i did
not ever agree with with uh with
mandates and the same thing with masks i
clearly said every community needs to
make the decisions of what is best for
them nikki
wait a minute my question's not answered
i'm sorry i'm asking the question
if you're california new york the way
that if you're saying he did such a
shitty job then you're saying others did
a good job so i'm asking you california
and new york what do you think they did
right that worked so effectively and
what do you think they did wrong that
didn't work so effectively i have never
done an analysis of what new york and
california did i was totally focused i
think you need to because people from
those states are moving to you and you
want to be the governor of this state
like if you want to be the governor of
the state i'm a guy that lived in texas
and california i need you to know why i
left california but i i'm telling you
what i would have done at the time of
our state okay i came out every single
day when when ron was not giving
information and that has been
his decisions aren't always necessarily
what my point of issue is my point of
issue is the fact that he made sure that
his opinion was the only opinion he
wasn't listening to any other advice he
wasn't listened to any other experts
besides the ones that he brought to the
table and you still you have a purple
state he won by 33 000 you had half of
the state that was scared you would half
the state that saw people that are dying
in hospitals that didn't know what
information to be given and then you
have somebody who comes on and yells at
anybody who doesn't agree with him he
didn't create a calmness he created
chaos he didn't bring people to the
table that may have different opinions
and talk through it it was his way or
the highway he changed the way that that
we were looking at data he brought down
the the um
the dashboard with all this information
people were going through this blind
without information so so do you think
all these people who are educated people
who have families kids from new york
california dc east coast who move to
florida are not paying attention to
these numbers like do you think they
came down here because they're oblivious
why do you think these families move
down here look i don't know why are they
the oblivious crowd that moved to
florida like listen he saw he sold this
this picture of what was happening in
the state of florida that we are the
free state of florida that we are open
but then if you go down to the policies
he was picking and choosing winners and
losers he was saying okay wwe in
jacksonville you can open up but the
rest of the state you can't
and then he was choosing which types of
different types of businesses were able
to have a seat at the table and even
with the vaccines look at how we
distributed the vaccines he first had
pop-up locations that were in affluent
communities he then put the vaccines
into publixes and as commissioner of
agriculture i know how many food deserts
are across the state of florida and
minority communities could not get
access to these vaccines
those were the issues that i had a
problem with you know whether or not to
have closed down when he did i asked to
be on the reopening task force that
because at this point he again not
bringing people to the table kept me off
of the reopening task force i enforced
when it came out with the reopening uh
task force and the recommendations i
actually supported them
i said these are these are methodical
these are well thought out and then he
completely scrapped it and just reopened
but i think we got to get back to this
issue
regardless of what happened with the
pandemic we got to go and move past it
you know we know i don't think we can
though
when it comes down to if you're if
you're talking about specific to this
topic i know what you're doing but i'm
talking in this stuff we're not past
this topic yet
why did so many educated people who care
about their kids and their wives and
their families and their husbands why
did they move to florida
should they all leave now no should they
go back to california texas should they
go back to new york they should go back
right if you're saying they made a
mistake coming down here because the
centers did a such a terrible job so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here